[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war this summary was
reported and recently confirmed by
entertainment weekly that hbo has
released a casting call for
princess rhaenyra targaryen a key figure
from this time period of the dance of
the dragons
the casting call describes her king
viserys's chosen heir
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
miguel sapochnick and ryan condole will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
the dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers dragons fought the
dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid
131ac one of the main characters in the
series is going to be rhaenyra targaryen
princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered as
the realms delight when she was young
and later called the half-year queen
was the first born child of king viserys
the first targaryen
reiner was king viserys is the first
only living child by his first wife
queen emma of house serene at the age of
eight she was made her father's heir
and grew up expecting to become the
first ruling queen of westeros
rainer was a dragon rider whose mount
was cyrex
rhaenyra had her family's valyrian looks
varying her silver gold hair in a long
braid in the manner of queen visenya
targaryen
beautiful as a child rhaenyra was later
declared by her uncle prince daemon
targaryen to be the most beautiful
maiden in all the seven kingdoms
due to the lack of a male heir viserys
designated rhaenyra as his successor
therefore rhaenyra was the only female
targaryen to lay claim to the iron
throne in her own right
since she was raised as the designated
heir rhaenyra became quite pampered and
arrogant
but also gained practical governmental
experience
after rhaenyra's mother died her father
remarried
and had several sons with his second
wife alicent of house hightower
even so viserys still publicly expected
his daughter to succeed him
and when he died his official will even
stated so
however rhaenyra's younger half-brother
aegon challenged her claim
he stated that the normal inheritance
laws of the andals
which formed the basis of the unified
law code in westeros
called for male preference primogeniture
meaning that a younger son would
rightfully inherit before an older
daughter
rhaenyra had two husbands and five sons
her first husband was lehner of house
valerian son of the sea snake
lenore and rhaenyra had three sons
together prince jacarys jace
lucerus luke and joffrey joff valerian
all were near adulthood and had dragons
of their own when rhaenyra's father
viserys the first died
it was rumored that those sons of
rhaenyras were actually fathered by her
champion and lover
harvin strong the strongest men in
westeros called
breakbones as all three were born with
brown hair and brown eyes
though leonard and rhaenyra both had
light silver gold hair and purple eyes
the greens were the ones who sparked
this rumor often calling them strongs
the true parentage of rhaenyra's three
eldest children is still unclear
the siblings lenore elena valerian who
were married to rhaenyra and daemon
targaryen
both died in 120 ac as did rhaenyra's
alleged lover break bones
rhaenyra then secretly married her uncle
prince daemon
the most experienced and the most
dangerous warrior of his time at
dragonstone
the news of their wedding caused a great
scandal at the court of king's landing
and made rhaenyra's father furious it
took some time before viserys and daemon
reconciled
rhaenyra's other sons prince aegon and
viserys targaryen were fathered by
daemon
and dole had targaryen features at the
time of her father's death
rhaenyra was done dragonstone evading
the birth of her child
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her until her own supporters in
the red keep were dead
or imprisoned and aegon the second's
coronation had already occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart the seven kingdoms
known as the dance of the dragons as it
was the only war in which both sides had
dragon riders
the war lasted for three years and by
the time it came to an end
nearly all of the targaryen dragons had
been killed the conflict also resulted
in the
death of three of rhaenyra's five sons
as well as the eldest son of fagon the
second
rhaenyra's personal sigil was the normal
targaryen heraldry
a three-headed red dragon and a black
field quartered with the moon and falcon
sigil of house serene
for her mother emmarin and the silver
seahorse on sea green of house valerian
for her first husband lana valerian as
well as for the valerians in general
who were among her major supporters
during the dance her faction used her
personal heraldry as her battle flag
aegon ii held many advantages in the war
including control of the capital city
the support of the lord commander of the
kingsguard and the approval of the high
septon rhinera's faction was based at
dragonstone
and to her advantage she had a larger
number of dragons under her control
12 to aegon's four although three of
these were wild dragons
and as yet untamed while another three
very mature
she also did not have enough targaryen
blood relatives on her side to ride all
of them
and the dragon will typically only bond
with someone possessing the blood of old
valyria
thus a search was launched to find any
surviving targaryen bastards
nicknamed the dragon seeds and enlist
them in rhaenyra's cause
the two factions during the war one
supporting aegon and the others
supporting rhaenyra
became known as the blacks and the
greens because of the incident that took
place at a tournament
some years before the war began egan
ii's mother queen elizandt had worn a
green dress to the tournament
while rhaenyra wore a black dress the
note was taken
and thereafter it became the custom to
refer to greens and blacks
when talking of the queen's party and
the party of the princess
respectively generally rhaenyra was
supported by noble families who had
enjoyed royal favor during her father's
reign
and possessed strong ties to the crown
while legend ii rallied
those who had been out of favor viserys
the first had signed charters with many
powerful houses
in which they soared to accept rhaenyra
as his heir
but at least some of them broke their
word after viserys died
rhaenyra sent her eldest son jacary
snort on his dragon to visit the erie
and then winterfell
at that time the whale was ruled by a
female heiress
who had inherited in her own right due
to a lack of male heirs
and given that the entire civil war
questioned a woman's right to rule
she and rhaenyra were natural allies
moreover the aryans had enjoyed royal
favor earlier in viserys's the first
reign
since his first wife rhaenyra's own
mother was an errand
thus binding the two families by blood
the starks came into the war on
rhaenyra's side in accordance with the
original agreements they had made with
viserys
rhaenyra's second son lucerus flew on
his dragon to storm's end
to gain an alliance with house baratheon
but reagan ii's brother aymond
flew to storm's end at the same time to
pursue the same goal
riding the older dragon vagar the
results were decidedly
mixed and storm zen subsequently
supported
aegon ii amend riding vagar killed luke
over
shipbreaker bay as he attempted to leave
after failing to gain lord boros
allegiance
the westerlands also sided with tagon ii
because he had appointed thailand
lannister as his new master of coin
the hightowers were of course staunch
supporters of aegon ii
and so apparently was much of the reach
dorne had not been incorporated into the
realm yet
and as they have often done throughout
history the iron islands remained
neutral
while the mainlanders slaughtered each
other although they did the blacks a
favor when they started attacking the
westerlands
at some point during the war ryner
herself was captured by aegon the second
forces
and was fed to her half brother's dragon
while her son was forced to watch
rhaenyra's three eldest sons all died
fighting during the dance of the dragons
but her two youngest sons the sons by
her second husband prince daemon
survived the civil war
rhaenyra supporters led by how stallion
house stark continued to fight on in the
name of her two surviving sons
however and eventually triumphed through
uncertain circumstances aegon ii died
without male heirs
and peace was achieved when rainer
zelda's surviving son was crowned as
zagan iii
he was the son who had been forced to
watch his mother consumed by a dragon
and he developed a deep hatred and fear
of the creatures
so many dragons had died in the war that
the targaryens could not maintain a
stable breeding population
and the few survivors became in bread
and sickly
the last targaryen dragons the last
dragons in the known world
died during the reign of aegon iii
earning him a subaru k
aegon the dragonbane aegon iii married
aegon ii
surviving daughter to reunite the
factions from the war
though many cadet branches and relatives
of house targaryen had been killed in
the war
aegon iii ruled well and both of his
sons there on the first and baylor the
first became kings after him
but each died childless therefore the
throne later passed to rhaenyra's
youngest son viserys ii
who had served as hand of the king under
his nephews for many years
viserys ii was the father of aegon iv
and grandfather of deron ii
and thereon ii was himself the
grandfather of aryan brightvain
aegon v the unlikely and maester aemon
neither rhaenyra or aegon ii are
remembered well in the history of estrus
and many argue that neither side truly
won at the end
but it's a fact that rhaenyra's
loyalists won the war and rainer's
children got the throne
let me know your thoughts about
everything the prequel its characters
especially rhaenyra in the comment
section down below
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one peace